they are presuming to regulate what goes
into people's bodies
therefore they end up actually
physically delving into people's bodies
to find these arbitrarily forbidden
substances Tim Byung happened in the
fall of 2012
David Eckert January of 2013 were both
stopped for alleged traffic violations
by members of the border task force the
border task force which is made up of
local law enforcement agents receives
federal dollars through a program called
Operation stone garden to fight the drug
war along the Mexican border running
Operation stone garden along the US
border for a long time and they continue
to give funds to local governments in
order to arrest their own citizens and
subject them to these humiliating
searches Timothy young lives in Deming
New Mexico with his wife and three
children
in October 2012 young was pulled over by
deputy Javier Peru in Lordsburg a town
about an hour west of Deming was at the
phalange stopped to get gas
I had a friend of mine along exited the
vehicle he's the deputy Peru
he stated that I need to get back in the
vehicle
ask him what what it was for what was
going on he said uh not use my turn
signal when Hidalgo County Sheriff's
found an open container belonging to
Young's companion in the car
young consented to a search of his truck
that lasted for more than two hours he
didn't tell you what it said no he said
that he said as far as he know that
there was nothing in they said they're
gonna break a nine and I said well you
know what that's fine don't have any
here on your vehicle Oh what the drug is
it good they're forming a diaper bag can
you watch these other changes oh yeah a
really good dogs with our department it
has there been any drugs inside that
vehicle and there's no drugs in there
now who's our winner
that weekend America's I gotta say there
are a whole bunch of studies that find
that most of the time when they alert
there is in fact no contraband so that
rate may range from 56% to 96% those are
very big error rates don't like those it
I don't like to be scheduled see that
anything
it wasn't until last year in one of
these cases out of Florida that the
Supreme Court explicitly said if a
well-trained police dog alerts to a car
that in itself is enough to justify
surgery I just checked him real good no
not yet anything on the driver's seat
inside the vehicle and then also on the
center console inside the do
but you thought you didn't do a real for
a pat-down right uh no I don't bring
down the sheet and the center console
while Sheriff starts warrant to search
Young's person deputy Patrick green
continued to interrogate young you have
it up your ass have it up what's the
[ __ ] question is that it's an honest
question have one up my ass you have
drugs in your energy I can trigger what
you have drugs in yes you have some of
your ass the Timothy young case raises a
lot of questions including an obvious
one why would young or anyone not
crossing a border or travelling by plane
put drugs in his anal cavity I have no
[ __ ] clue so it's crazy I mean
there's all the way describe it the
sheriff's got a warrant and transported
young to the Gila Regional Medical
Center an hour away in Silver City New
Mexico I actually my stomach actually my
pelvic area and they didn't find nothing
it was negative
that being said they still took me back
to them to the ER officers present they
said they were going to do a anal finger
at him as soon as he penetrated they
left after not finding nothing in the
stool but still then they still get me
handcuffed now wrote Hank up to all the
way that hour drive back down to
Lordsburg where they've took me back to
my job and was respiratory's it's
probably but through four weeks after
after in fact and I go mailbox and open
the mailbox and there's a bill from
healer Medical Center for that night
that we're speaking on and I left I mean
that's all I could do was laugh one of
the crowd but I just left just a few
months later New Mexico cops set their
sights on another anal cavity
David Eckert was pulled over in the
Walmart parking lot in Deming for
failing to come to a complete stop at a
stop son Eckert was interrogated and
when he refused to allow officers to
search his car he didn't know that he
was about to be detained and tormented
for 14 hours Hidalgo County deputy
sheriff's arredondo and green the two
members of the border task force who
were also involved in the young case
arrived on the scene with the dog Leo
dog was brought in a police officer
claimed that the dog alerted we have a
dispute about that and that was enough
to get a warrant to search this guy and
his innards the first hospital they went
to the doctors didn't have anything to
do with it they said this doesn't seem
ethical to us they went to another
hospital they're like Oh Cheryl Dutch
they gave him three animals to prepare
him for a colonoscopy because he had eat
and so they wanted to clear what they're
going to search
and he was just humiliated they also did
just a digital examination of his rectum
which does not involve computers it's
you know they use put their fingers up
his butt basically so basically you know
anally raping him and every one of these
searches fails to find any contraband
Timothy Young and David Eckert brought
suits against everyone involved so far
Young has been awarded nine hundred and
twenty five thousand dollars from
Hidalgo County and David Eckert has been
awarded one point six million dollars
from Hidalgo County and the city of
Deming and who exactly is paying for
these judgments judgment against them is
paid for it by the local government
either in direct funds or in increased
premiums for their insurance policies so
the taxpayer is going to be paying for
these judgments if I would have done
that to somebody else you think I'd be
held accountable you don't right I'll be
held accountable I would have a rape
charge sitting in jail right now because
that's what it is
of course but for the war on drugs all
of these actions would be treated as
crimes we would we would view the police
and the doctors who are involved in
these actions as criminals rightly so
York Attorney's Office actually approved
the warrant so there's no accountability
as far as that goes
there's no way that my client can get
these officers disciplined or fired so
there's no method to do that other than
the sheriff or the Chief of Police
and that hasn't been done as far as we
know so there has been no accountability
for the officers and that's that's a sad
reality of what's happened you know
fundamentally when you look at a
situation like the search of David
Eckert what was this all about even
assuming the dog was well-trained even
if they did everything correctly even if
they found drugs it's about putting a
human being through a kind of torture
this humiliating awful painful
experience so you can find this
arbitrarily prescribed chemical they
should be held accountable and normally
I would be on this camera but it's got
to stop somewhere
it does have stuff somewhere